we're joined now by a member of
president-elect joe biden's new
coronavirus advisory board that's dr
michael ulsterholm he's an
epidemiologist
and director of the center for
infectious disease research and policy
at the university of minnesota good to
see you always good to have you here see
you again
thank you very much gail yeah i'm so
glad you're here because now we've got
not one but two
drugs who are going for emergency use
authorization
why are you so encouraged by this this
sounds like great news
it is great news i think we have a light
at the end of the tunnel
uh but we have to get to the end of the
tunnel and i think that that's what is
really sobering today
is the challenges we have before we're
going to see most americans having
access to this vaccine
so here's a big question as team biden
started talking to team trump
because now we're going to have to
figure out a way to coordinate all this
have those conversations begin
the transition team is in fact talking
to the administration to the senior
leadership at the
department of health and human services
and that's a really good thing
are you getting the information you need
michael
uh we are we're getting information uh
relative to
you know what's being done i think the
challenge is what is being done is not
nearly enough
right now i have a major fear that
although these vaccines will start to
become more available over the next
several months
many americans won't take them because
of the fear that there are some safety
issues with the vaccine
we have done nothing to really reassure
americans what these vaccines are
what they will do how they will work and
why they're so important
what should we be doing how do we get
that what should we be right now we need
to
yeah now's a good time to start with the
reassurance michael that was a good time
i'm happy to do that and tell you that
these vaccines are going to make all the
difference between dying
from this virus and living and and
beating this virus
these vaccines are going to be very safe
relative to
any other vaccines we use out there
these vaccines are going to likely be
quite effective at least in the earliest
days
and all the rumors that there's
something unusual about
the vaccines that make them dangerous
are not true they're rumors and that's
it
and we have to reassure people i'd be
the very first person in line to take
this vaccine
but there are others who need it more
than i do right now and i think that's
the message we have to get out
in in the black indigenous and
communities of color
we have a lot of distrust as high as 75
percent
of these populations don't believe this
vaccine is safe we have got to give them
the information so that
they themselves can judge why they want
to take this vaccine
if you've had covet do you still have to
get a vaccine michael
yes at this point we're saying go ahead
and get a vaccine again to make sure
that you have adequate protection we
believe that the a clinical case will
give you good protection
but we want to be sure so rather than
try to distinguish who has
and who hasn't had it everyone will
basically be in line for the vaccine
according to what the
recommendations will be forthcoming from
the cdc tomorrow
michael there are a hundred thousand
people in the hospital right now
uh as dr fauci said over the weekend
we're in the middle of his surge
he believes there will be a surge upon
that surge
how bad do you think the next few weeks
are going to be
well you know it's at this point uh tony
or
alan it's really hard to say i meant to
say anthony thank you
it's hard to say in the sense that uh i
we look at where we're at 200 000 just
two months ago we were at
40 000. we could go much higher than 200
000. i think that happened during
thanksgiving is in fact a lot like a 100
mile an hour wind now coming into a very
intense
uh forest fire and we don't have a clue
yet
could this go up another 50 60 000 cases
a day
it sure is possible what i also worry
about then is we're going to see
the virus activity then slingshot into
the christmas holiday season
and we have many more people who are
going to travel for that
michael a lot of people as you know
broke the rules now they're going back
home to families we hear
different things about quarantining do
you still have to quarantine for 14 days
what's the answer
and then we've got to get we got to let
you go george what's the answer
sure it's it no not 14 at this point i
think if you say
10 days maybe even seven days that will
be
more than adequate right now for what we
need to do all right
michael ostrom thank you very much for
being with us this morning